let's get into that first story we have
an exclusive
for timcast.com from cassandra fairbanks
family of jake gardner files wrongful
death lawsuit against county
special prosecutor and attorney
general's office i just want to read the
opening of this because it's a very
serious and very important story
cassandra writes the parents of a
nebraska bar owner that committed
suicide
after a fatal altercation with violent
rioters have filed a wrongful death
lawsuit against the county
the attorney general two unnamed
detectives and the special prosecutor in
the case
gardner 38 shot and killed a rider who
was attacking him
his elderly father and his business
during last summer's black lives matter
riots
prior to his suicide he was indicted by
a grand jury on counts of manslaughter
use of a firearm in the commission of a
felony
attempted first degree assault and
making terroristic threats
but only after intense political
pressure was placed on the city
the lawsuit accuses the plaintiffs of
conspiring to deprive
gardner of his right to a fair trial and
due process deprivation of sixth
amendment rights
deprivation of 14th amendment rights a
brady rule violation wrongful death
and failing to prevent the deprivation
of his rights gardner was a marine
and veteran of deployments to iraq and
haiti he described himself as a
libertarian but voted for donald trump
in 2016
and volunteered for his campaign in
three states the district attorney had
originally ruled that the shooting was
self-defense on may 30th garner
confronted a group of rioters outside
one of the bars he owned in omaha called
the hive
one of them had just violently attacked
his seventy-year-old father which was
captured on surveillance footage
during the chaos gardner was knocked to
the ground the veteran fired a warning
shot
and attempted to back away the situation
took a tragic turn
after 22 year old rioter james scurlock
jumped on his back and began
choking him the veteran could be heard
pleading with his assailant saying get
off me get off me please get off me
according to the lawsuit the choking
lasted at least 18 seconds
before gardner fatally shot scurlock
skurlock had repeatedly broken windows
at gardner's bar and other businesses in
the area earlier that evening
still the fatal shooting sparked even
more riding in the city which escalated
after donald klein the douglas county
attorney
determined that gardner had acted in
self-defense and declined to bring
charges
in what appeared to be a political move
to quell the riots douglas county
district attorney
shelly stratman appointed special
prosecutor frederick d franklin to
handle the case
though the court said that they expected
the same outcome franklin is president
of the midlands bar association
organization
for black only attorneys the lawsuit
notes the special prosecutor had heavily
implied gartner was a racist
when he announced the charges at the
height of the racial tension in the
nation
by saying the decision was not made
because he quote may or may not have
been a racist because
being racist is not against the law
yikes man
there were no hints of racism in the
gardner messages in the in in gardner's
message
or messages or reasons for franklin to
imply that he was
there was the special special prosecutor
inflamed people so much
that gardner received more than 1 600
death threats that week
his family was also forced to move out
of the state for fear their of their own
safety now
the story goes on a bit more there's
there's a statements from the the lawyer
involved
but i want to point out something really
important as we move through the next
you know bit of stories this guy got 1
600 death threats
i'm fairly convinced none of those
people will face any kind of
repercussion for those death threats
but you know for a fact if the person
was in any way anti-establishment
right-wing or populist then that would
have been all over the news as the
extremists are coming et cetera et
cetera
i got to say this story is
nightmarish it's coming back up because
you know this lawsuit
but here's the guy who begs you know get
off me
he had already warned him several times
those warnings terroristic threats
so saith the state the prosecutor
telling someone like back away you know
i'm armed that's making threats now it's
terroristic threats
things look uh i don't know they look
fairly dark i suppose now to be fair
this happened
you know last year and the lawsuit is
bringing this back up so i don't act
like
we're seeing more of this kind of thing
specifically we haven't had the level of
riots we had during the george floyd
riots
but you take a look at the chauvin case
which wasn't that long ago and you get
riots and you know the jurors are scared
of retaliation i think more than one
juror said that they were scared right
do you guys remember i know there was
one alternate i heard though and there
i think there's another guy who said
like yeah we yeah there were two of them
yeah
and now we have the the written house
trial coming up
i i am not convinced rittenhouse will
get a fair trial
and a lot of people have said that they
think he will and i'm like
why would why would anybody go up
against this machine where
you can send these people can send all
these death threats and nothing bad
happens to them
that they can go around these people are
literally destroying buildings and
attacking people and
they're called the victims yeah i don't
know i don't know man
it's kind of an example of uh how like
law
law is one thing but you got to kind of
put the law aside when you're looking at
what's going on
right now around the world violence is
the last resort
absolute last last desperation resort
you do not do it because if you do it
court of public opinion goes after you
you see sixteen hundred people issued
this guy death threats
sixteen hundred people they were going
to go well he received 1600 death
threats maybe something
as far as he was concerned his life was
over so he took his own life like
that that was without the legal system i
mean obviously the legal system was
busting this guy's balls too
but i mean i think the common thread
here is that it's the politicization of
our reality and in violent instances is
where it's the most maybe pronounced but
like
i mean just look at obviously all the
all the covid stuff yeah sorry if i'm
quiet there folks i'll
get a little closer here there we go um
with all the kovitz stuff i mean there's
you know it's or if you want to talk
about the quote unquote lab leak
hypothesis
um that was politicized because you know
trump went one way and everybody else
went the other
and so there was there was that one
doctor who said it that we initially
dismissed this because it was trump who
said it am i allowed to say covet on
youtube yeah yeah
but be careful because sure okay if you
say if you add the 19 afterwards no i'm
kidding
they got weird rules the rules are
absolutely weird yeah yeah
i'm aware of them for sure the weird
thing is like if biden farted in public
and someone recorded it on their iphone
that would become political
because of why social media and biden if
biden voided
his bowels because of his old age they
would claim that it's completely normal
uh it's like oh it's not a big deal it's
a normal thing don't worry about it
do you see the tens of thousands of
views on twitter comments
retweets i gotta be honest probably get
banned they'd say it's fake it's
manipulated it's manipulated he didn't
actually avoid his bowels he just took a
dump
i'm one public if we need to change the
way our courts work like because
how can we get a fair trial in this day
and age i got to stress this point man
i think the law is absolutely uh well i
shouldn't say absolutely
i'm cause i'm exaggerating but i think
the law is very much so meaningless in a
certain
in a certain sense obviously we follow
the laws we recognize what laws
you know uh you know what the laws are
to the best of our abilities there's a
lot of laws people don't know about
i was watching this video on never
talking to cops and the guy points out
it's a crime
to accept like see see uh
creatures like seafood or creatures or
whatever from someone
if they obtained it uh oh it's like if
it's illegal in another country
to obtain it and they trade it to you
you committed a crime in the u.s like
there are laws that are really
really weird right the problem is though
we can follow the laws to the best of
our abilities we can live peacefully we
say you know violence is wrong
the the issue though is it's cultural if
the law is
don't do x but no one's willing to
prosecute it the law may as well not
exist
right so if the the law may as well
right the law
may as well right now be do not you know
vandalism
destruction of private property is a
crime a felony punishable
by up to a year in jail or some class a
mismeter punishable about by up to a
year in jail
if you're right-wing that's what it
should say or it should say you know uh
an exemption is included for anyone who
who toes the establishment line like the
age-old situation is if you have the mob
the crowd the populace on your side
the court's gonna side with you they're
gonna get you off or they're gonna
prosecute who you want to prosecute and
if you know the
the judge they're gonna get you off sort
of i think that i think that's how it
kind of used to be yeah but knowing the
judge was
connections and access to resources
there's something that
there's there's two motivating factors
here one would be greed
where the judge is like oh that's you
know so-and-so's kid you know if i
could do him a favor the other is fear
oh if i don't prosecute this guy they're
going to show up and burn my house down
whatever they say so now we have to a
two-tiered justice system it's
you can call it a narco tyranny or you
can call it something worse
you've got ideological courts where
they'll be like well they're protesting
arrest the guy give him all the charges
in the book he's going to prison
and then when the death threats come in
we don't care
no one's protesting that so long as
regular people
the politically homeless conservatives
whatever don't protest
they've lost they've lost their their
chance in my opinion to be to be
completely honest too
there was maybe a period five six years
ago where the right could have gone out
and done big mass peaceful protests
now you get a handful of guys to walk
out with american flags and they'll
scream the far right's coming the far
right's coming
the media will claim you're a white
supremacist or a nazi and they'll shut
it down in two seconds
how do you fix it do you get the jurors
all over the world to port in on like
video chat and listen to the trial and
then vote anonymously
well i mean i think it's the real
problem here is that our court system
everybody's so accessible now so like
everybody's a public figure in some way
you know so if you're if you're a juror
or if you get doxxed
you know basically people can access you
and it's not fun getting death threats
i mean 1500 of them is that's a lot of
1600
1600 and i mean i've gotten maybe i
don't know
100 something like that but
like none of those none of those get
taken seriously they don't go after any
of those people
if they makes you feel unsafe for sure
just you know
tangentially like you know there's a
digital world and there's a real world
but you think about the crossover
and like you know i guess i guess the
problem is if they started prosecuting
stuff immediately
it maybe you never would have gotten
this far in the first place like they
they are
letting it get worse and worse until i
think there's going to be a snap
like when regular people don't feel safe
anymore and they just lose their mind
you know what i mean it's like it's
almost like enduring some kind of
torture
where every day you you're inundated
with these stories about violence
against regular people
about how the the justice system is
against you and then you just
you don't feel safe right so there was
this um this report a while ago
i was talking about the arab spring and
i might be getting this wrong but i
believe that they basically said like
there's there's uh three things that
people need
and it's food shelter and security they
need to know
the security is there is their knowledge
that they can exist they can survive
they'll be able to you know live they
need a place to live
and they need to eat food and if you
take one of those things away
in large enough numbers you'll get a
revolution so
security is extremely important the idea
that people feel safe and secure and can
trust
that they won't be gulagged i suppose
but that's going away it's it's going
away when you get when you get to
stories like this
and you get everything we've seen now i
think the written house thing is going
to be
really serious uh because i you know you
know you don't got to say anything i'll
say it
i'll actually i'll i'll quote destiny
you know destiny was he's a leftist we
had him on the show
and he said it was the clearest case
clearest cut case of self-defense he had
ever seen
kyle rittenhouse and what happened now i
obviously can't say anything
on that because right but playing the
role of witness makes you acutely aware
i mean because you you that's a role
your role is to say what you saw
and not inject you know any opinion on
that
and just like based on the media
coverage that happened after kenosha
i was i was viewed one way or another by
this group or that and by the way i'm no
friend of either side because i'm
also a victim in that case thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you